congrats to you too buddy congrat don't
bury the lady no i haven't seen you
since i think i'm a married woman no and
you were pregnant nashville yesterday
how was it it looked beautiful
beautiful but girl you are totally
burying the lady here
you know what i'm talking about to do
that
you make it not hiding this you make it
look so fly oh thank you
how are you feeling what are you
enjoying most about this journey uh
donuts so far
but besides the obvious you know
i'm looking forward to it you know this
is it's all an exciting journey so far
i'm just taking it as it comes every
week it's something new and i'm just
taking it i i'm enjoying it but you were
making it look so stylish
well you have to right see that i mean
so it's a long nine to ten months girl
you know you you have to enjoy it you
were making it your fashion show i'm
trying to enjoy it as much as i could
and fashion is one of my favorite things
so you know redefining what it means to
even be
pregnant and maternal you know it always
it it can get uncomfortable at times so
you know you can dress the part and
pretend
you were glowing though but i mean i
think you're also going because of fenty
beauty fenty skin we are also here
tonight to celebrate it so yeah what's
your beauty regimen looking like these
days
um
staying moisturized from head to toe you
know but a drop is my go-to
and i know
i know thank you so much is there one
product that you feel like you cannot
leave home without uh
gloss bomb
glass bomb for sure the mvp you're
wearing yes it is oh look at you lala
baby
and do i smell like you ready yay well
if you smell like me it's probably
because you're wearing it um
when are we going to get fenty baby
well
one thing at a time
okay well let's talk about this other
baby that we all want to know about
when is this maybe do you think this
stage in your life is going to inspire
new music
oh gosh
you can't ever you know that's why my
fans love you you know because you asked
all the good questions
uh well
yes you're still gonna get music from me
maybe a lullaby i can see you and asap
dropping demos in the studio oh my
goodness not a lullaby my fans would
kill me they waited this long for a
lullaby letting us sleep with this music
they're like we are grown yeah exactly
uh valentine's day is coming up so what
is the most savage women around have
planned for her man and what is she
expecting from her options you know just
pulling them out my uh my little closet
your birthday happy birthday mom thank
you i'm getting older older older wiser
yes
[Music]